Biden sues Texas over new law making
illegally crossing the border an
arrestable offense let me tell you
something guys article 4 section four
shout out to Josie the redhead
libertarian constitutional scholar uh
article 4 section 4 says the federal
government must defend States from
Invasion from outside forces and here we
are witnessing 10,000 people per day
storming invading Texas it's an invasion
in fact MSNBC was shocked by it that's
what really got me watching an MS MSNBC
reporter being like my god I've never
seen anything like this the Biden
Administration is fighting against the
Constitution and the law now I ask you
how the how is it that the Biden
Administration is getting away with
on the
Constitution spitting on the laws of the
country and the
state how is it possible you ask how do
we win against a system that is corrupt
it's not about a system it is not about
numbers in a book codification it is
about how many people agree with your
worldview and how many don't and right
now we're at the point where Joe Biden
has under his command men and women who
are willing to do whatever he says
regardless of whether or not they are
serving or opposing the United States I
see this story and I think it's really
plain to see the the the doj has gone
Rogue they are acting against the
Constitution which says they must defend
against invasion they are facilitating
Invasion aiding and abetting outside
forces to who harm this country that is
sedition and so as we witness this we
wonder how is it possible the federal
government has people within it because
it's not the entirety of the FBI it's
like the DC Bureau there are FBI agents
in other parts of the country that are
fine how is it that these people are
able to engage in sedition there are no
good men or women willing to stand up
and say you are rogue you are criminals
police officer at a local police
department in New York hypothetical Robs
a Bank steals the cash and walks out and
he says I'm a cop what are you going to
do about it well Internal Affairs shows
up and says we're here to arrest and he
goes oh heavens me oh no I've been
caught law enforcement got me one day
the police chief himself for the entire
NYPD decides to rob a bank and he does
and he says I'm the I'm the chief of
everybody what are you going to do about
it and they go oh G goly what do we do
the FBI shows up they arrest the they
arrest the cop there's a law enforcement
agency above superseding in the Biden
Administration there's nobody they are
the highest level and they are
committing criminal acts against the
people of this country every single day
and you need only look to the people of
Chicago to see that they're outright
saying crimes are Comm being committed
against us the victims are apparent and
many of these migrants are victims as
well being promised Glory when they come
here and then dying in the desert mhm
Texas says this is illegal and we will
stop it federal law says this is illegal
and we must stop it a border patrol
agent turned away illegal immigrants
before they entered the US and he is now
under investigation by the feds a man
who did the right thing and said you got
to turn around you can't come in the
country and the FEDS are now going after
him so when I talk about how you win
this there's only one way you win
it a federal law enforcement officer
that is willing to engage in a seditious
conspiracy against the government
against this country working with the
government I suppose I think it's
fascinating that people ask me how Civil
War could happen and I'll tell you this
very very simply when federal law
enforcement agents are engaged in a
seditious conspiracy to violate the con
they're violating the Constitution and
abetting an invasion at our Southern
border you need to ask me how a civil
war Could Happen youo are
outright destroying your country in
plain view and there's no law
enforcement to stop them except for
Texas Texas has declared it illegal the
Biden Administration their move so far
is to sue Texas if good men and women in
Texas in law enforcement say we will
enforce the law get the out of our
way we're done all you need is for good
men to do something how do we win this
you need to wake these people up and let
them know the crime is happening and I
assure you good people will wake up we
are witnessing the Decay and the decline
of wokeness the budlight boycotts target
boycotts Donald Trump's polling numbers
through the roof the American people are
starting to wake up to the corruption
that is the Deep state that is the unip
party what is ineffective homie shows up
and starts opening fire on a bunch of
federal agents that reinforces their
view that they're the good guys it puts
them in the victim position and then
regular people who don't know what's
going on lend their power support and
voice to the criminals what we need to
happen is to control the lines of
communication set the news cycle and we
have to win those institutions the the
termination the resignation of these
University professors and it was real
difficult to get rid of Claud and gay is
one of the most powerful moves in
winning the culture war and putting an
end to any potential violence and taking
back the seats of power it's not just
that though the daily wies efforts in
producing content like bent key
inspiring young people I told you the
reason why pedophilia is so evil and why
more more evil than murder is because it
destroys the future generations of
humanity what the daily wire is doing
with beny is reinforcing and
strengthening the future generations of
humanity that is how we win now I know a
lot of people say Tim you don't have
kids hey none of your business working
on it but that's the other issue let
liberals we stand I shouldn't say let
them but we watch them as they sterilize
their kids abort their kids all signs
indicate that we are on a path towards
Victory the answer is not going to be
someone deciding to act outside of the
system we are seeking to regain control
of it would be like the United States is
this great gallion of the 17th century
and it was once captained by a great man
named uh I don't know was a John Paul
Jones I guess I don't know if he ever
Captain to Gall or anything like that
but uh uh let's say we had a great
Captain well you know what over a long
period of time some pieces of took
control of that ship the answer is not
to burn that ship to the ground and blow
it up and sink it because it's doing bad
it's to get in convince enough of
those controlling that
ship to Mutiny against the corrupt and I
wouldn't even call it a mutiny I would
say stop supporting the criminal a
pirate has taken command of this ship
and you know it's wrong we are winning
that fight and we are getting
institutional push back Texas as an
institution operating under the law with
the confidence of the people has
declared what Biden is doing illegal and
Biden is trying to stop him but it may
be only a year from today that we are
witnessing the preparations for the
inauguration of Donald Trump in which he
promises to mass Deport through a simple
and legal process that will be arduous
but simple and the arrest of many people
people I I say no guarantees Donald
Trump may or may not do this who knows
but at least at least this is the most
effective plan and path forward winning
people over winning hearts and minds and
convincing your enemies or the default
liberals to stand side by side with you
instead of fighting against you if you
went to any world leader and said good
sir which would you rather have victory
over your enemies through Bloodshed
violence and bombs or without a single
bullet being fired say of course I would
rather just win victory of my enemies
without a bullet being fired my friends
I introduce you to information Warfare
controlling the minds of the younger
generation and figuring out how to do
that effectively is how you'll win the
war without even raising a finger and
that's what they've been doing with big
Tech I I'll tell you this right now as
an aside we learned this they did not
count Our Song sales for the song
together again and I know I know it's
unrelated to a certain degree they told
us the only way to track sales now as of
June June 29th of this of 2023 of last
year is to go through iTunes and Amazon
that's right if you want your music to
count on their charts you got to suck
the dick of big Tech
because they know the game they're
playing they want to make sure you go
through their tunnel and you go through
their paths and there's no other way so
we've got to fight back they know what
they're doing and they've got a long
game but the game is not to play into
the hands of breaking the system it's to
figure out how you navigate past them
and take control we have been doing that
wonderfully think about how we can go on
Twitter and say think about how
we can say again I've been
saying it a lot in 2018 if you said men
are not women you would have been banned
now you can certainly say that so the
victory is right before us and it may
come to the point where many of you are
correct violence is what happens but
that
is when that point comes it's when
there's nothing left and all that can be
convinced have been
convinced and that's a sad a sad reality
that we uh we don't want to see anybody
claiming they want to see violence I I
believe the majority of them have never
experienced it that's why most of these
veterans they tell you don't want it
they they tell you man you you you will
not want to see what happens because
it's not going to be it's not going to
be some glorious battle between the good
guys and the bad guys it's going to be
the Hunger Games and as much as I think
the movie was really poorly made the
final message in The Hunger Games
prequel was the main character coryana
snow who becomes the president quite
literally saying the point of The Hunger
Games is to remind people of what they
really are the whole world is the arena
and I'm the Victor that was the point
when when Society breaks down when
security breaks down you're not in some
righteous battle with good and evil it's
just the Hunger Games so I got to tell
you man when people say to me oh the
system you you you can't work it's too
rigged and and and they advocate for
violence I'm like you will lose
read some sunsu you got to win the war
before the war starts let me stress that
again you have to win the war before it
starts that is the Art of War it's one
of the tenants of The Art of War what
that means is if this is destined to
become violent you need to have already
won it before it gets to that point that
means Donald Trump wins law enforcement
comes in and maybe it does get violent
maybe the far-left Rampages through the
streets burning things down but the
institutions are under our control
American values are being reaffirmed and
reinst the constition now being defended
and they lost before it even began the
fighting may happen but we have to
control as many institutions as possible
before it does otherwise we lose anyway
rant over thanks for listening to my
dead talk so it I agree fully I think
there's something that that's really
good that's been happening which is that
there's these fracture points which kind
of surpass someone's political bias some
of the things you brought up right so
the claudian gay thing the anti-Semitism
issue there was in so many liberal Jews
faces that they started having to
question their own identities you see it
with the Trans movement you see it with
these little issues that keep popping up
where the left is losing because they're
so against objective reality and I think
the more culture fights against those
fracture points those are the winning
issues if we really focus on those we
have a chance of winning people over and
I think especially with a lot of liberal
Jews I've been talking to there's a huge
shift there huge wakeup call with the
support for Hamas and this is what's
causing universities to to to to uh
fracture thanks for watching this clip
from the timcast IRL podcast hang out
with us live Monday through Friday at
8:00 p.m. and become a member over at
timcast.net